ah look at my shirt put my fanny pack
dude
my name is razzmatazz I'm the gayest guy
alive
no he changes the amount of driver's
license his name is Dan says you I don't
[ __ ] my car dude there's an epidemic now
a phenomenon of fake hate crimes they've
increased dramatically there have
actually been more fake hate crimes in
just November of 2016 than the entire
year of 2015 and the goal generally
speaking of these fake hate crimes is to
incite racial hatred against other
people it's Republicans Tea Partiers
Trump voters whites people who don't
watch Fox
take your pick it's essentially created
an entire cottage industry of people
accusing other people of crimes and
trying to get more time tacked on or
trying to get a worse sentence tacked on
because of a politically incorrect
motivated hate crime you are about to
enter the hate crime court the people
are real the cases maybe this is
razzmatazz he's accusing the defendant
of striking him with a baseball bat
twice in the ribs because he's a
homosexual this is not gay Jared he
claims razzmatazz is full of [ __ ]
Honorable Judge van andel presiding
please rise so Jared it appears you
assaulted the razzmatazz with a baseball
bat striking him twice in the rib cage
now you are being charged with assault
with a deadly weapon with your honor as
a gay man I requested he gets the hate
crime amount of years like a lot of
years not the normal amount you give
normal people I want you to uh you know
be hate crime mate Your Honor this man
is not gay I caught him having sex with
my wife he just wants me to go to prison
baby can crime her on her
this man was motivated by pure
homophobia as he was striking me he was
saying stuff like maybe there's a
teacher from being gay and sucking off
dudes give him hell your honor could
they just bought that wig today from Hot
Topic you can see the tags ah wig it's
my hair I also really like My Chemical
Romance your honor mr. Esmond says you
mean to tell me that you are a
homosexual but we're engaging
relations with this man's watch well
it's very complicated thing your honor
yes I'm gay
I prefer dad exclusively have sex with
women give him he'll Your Honor hate
crime me well I'm quite certain he
struck you because you were having sex
with his wife look at my shirt with my
fanny-pack dude my name's razzmatazz I'm
the gayest guy alive
no he changes the amount of driver's
license his name is Dan says you I'm a
fox mark I dunno mister razzmatazz
that's not how hate crimes work
sentencing is required to determine
motivation that the crime was committed
because the victim is a part of a
marginalized group I just told you he
was hitting me because I'm a fairy and
not because I was having sex with his
wife never happened it's true your honor
I was there he repeatedly beat him and
called this man effective while we were
doing it thanks Ben
top five hate crimes and what kind one
through this we were all does that
qualify as a hate crime and you realize
that almost anything can qualify as a
hate crime yeah just just figure out an
angle and just stick a do don't figure
out any angle are you did you have a
crime committed against you are you a
woman
hate crime so number number five I think
we had to start with this one because
this is a big part of the whole new safe
space movement to poop schwa Stuka at
Mizzou so this was one in case you
forgot the media and college claimed
that this was a white supremacist hate
crime
there was a poop swastika can you say a
phrase straight
I don't you masca in it's one of those
things I think everyone looked at and
thought this is likely not true but we
can't necessarily better even know it
was true like it's kind of sucks the
person who made the poop swastikas they
got poop all over them well you know
there's a saying that extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
death I would argue that the poop schwa
Stuka is an extraordinary claim in
reality there was never any evidence for
there was a lot of evidence guys take
pictures of three-pound dung keys in the
toilet - it's shut off you would take a
picture there would be evidence of a
booze but there would be one guy who did
the poo schwozzam some dummy would take
a picture with his noun now didn't
happen all right on to number four our
favorite resident non black black guy
chief Shawn King claim he was beaten up
because he was black the police report
showed actually
the boxes were checked I think we have
these it was non-hispanic and white
that's the actual police report of a
hate crime committed and the detective
who worked on it actually had no record
of hate crimes committed not only this
but in the district and as more evidence
emerged it seemed to actually stem from
a domestic dispute it did not seem as
though white black eye Shaun King was
abused did you just realize dawn saying
that the media not do any checking right
away and when it came to antiphon we did
our infiltration and honey-b was
arrested we had the police reports we
had the arrest records we were looking
for mug shots we're going okay what what
has been written up to me was a hall a
second Shaun King has made his entire
career off of being the victim of a hate
crime let's look at the Oh hold on he's
a rock check why prophet he's famous for
just being black and he's white
that's the only thing number three this
one we could have a whole list under
this under this this is a category in
and of itself but my favorite one is the
gay pastor who alleged that whole foods
cake decorators in Austin discriminate
against him because his cake red Love
Wins
remember that there's so many of these
there was a lesbian with the bad tip
that said something like calling her a
anti-gay so it turns out she did it on
the receipt or whatever yeah now this
guy when he was caught on tape later
admitted that he had done it himself
I loved his statement this is one where
the guys just tried it out there's no
there's no semblance of him being
innocent the company did nothing wrong I
was wrong to pursue this matter and use
the media to perpetuate this story it's
almost like a game plan think about this
for a second this is what matters when
it comes to the hate crime deal because
this was a national news story so
lesbian receipt was a national news
story we were in Utah with an tyfa
having handed you an ice pick and a
knife and talking about sawed-off
shotguns in their car and luring people
in maggots their generous hearts wolf we
handed this footage over to reporters in
the presence of police watching it
saying look this detectives going to
watch this footage so you can confirm
that it's real Nightline had no interest
in it one lesbian with a bowl cut says
this guy didn't tip me and they send out
Brian Williams they're like now this
pastor called himself a sorry boy yeah
we've got real
yeah number two this one is pretty some
people would say this isn't a hate crime
mattress girl you know where's mattress
girl name was Emma Sokka what so the
reason everyone knew this was because
she was the feminist hero du jour was
HuffPo slate salon she carried her
mattress around the campus and the
reason was
quit freaking probably everyone knows
what this is about she claimed that she
was raped and this was her cross to bear
cross to bear it was with a German
exchange student and she went on to
report him from rape eight months later
all of the evidence that emerged he was
cleared of all charges
she's still carrying her mattress around
as far as I know and this is what what
this comes out to do rape culture people
go why you just taking an extreme
example like antiphon
these little chips add up rape culture
was established by a handful of cases
UVA mattress girl this is what was used
to create this narrative that there's
there's no actual recourse women who
were raped on campus men are getting
away it's just there it's like it's
women and falling out of the sky rape
victims on college campus rape culture
one in four women because of story after
story after story and you never hear
about the fact that the story wasn't
false just like hands up don't shoot was
hands weren't up he was assaulting a cop
you move on down the ladder dev is out
there it gets its carried away corn game
on national news then when you find out
the next day she had a shotgun aimed at
the police and her boy in another hand
should go find dad they bury that
footage and they move on down to the
next victim case to build their
narrative of brutal police officers same
thing with rape culture mattress grill
is one of many stories which brings us
to the number-one eight crime that I
think has been most corrosive to the
fabric of our society the Duke Lacrosse
rape hoax for people who don't know this
was a perfect this was just an absolute
dream story for the media because it was
young white males who allegedly raped a
female a black female stripper so let me
read this for me this was members of the
Duke lacrosse team hired two shippers
for a party and we're accused of rape
three players who were arrested for the
rape were deemed innocent the district
attorney so what's important the
district attorney who pursued the case
despite evidence to the contrary was
disbarred and those in the media that
push a narrative looked like fools this
is an article here's the thing the
district attorney what happens there's a
consequence he knew there was evidence
in the contrary that's why he was
disbarred you're not disbarred because
you lose you're disbarred because you
knowingly ignore evidence of the
contrary the media having access to the
exact same information by the time this
story was published no consequences the
people
during it are still at their posts
that's what's so disconcerting the
meeting they're never called on any of
their bullcrap they get away with it for
years and years and again everyone it
was afraid to talk about because when
we'll hate crimes
no one likes hate no one wants to be
hateful I'm not hateful yeah we did hate
crime laws sure hate speech and they
don't understand that they are slowly
giving away their rights the First
Amendment right and then of course we
have Vegas and then it's a Second
Amendment right and then they say that
health care in school and debt absolving
is a human right when it's not when the
actual human rights that we have in this
country are not even recognized it is
the death by a thousand cuts rape
culture racist cops racist culture white
supremacist and it's based on little
stories like this and grow and grow and
grow until all of a sudden you lose
track of where you should be
see Your Honor this is pure gay hate
here give him that big gay Center Your
Honor I I can't believe this direct
you're not falling for this are you now
unfortunately there's nothing I can do
this man is claiming that you struck him
because he is a practicing homosexual
and there is indeed a witness your honor
this is all circumstantial I mean how
can you how do you legally tell if
someone is gay anyways well now this
seems pretty cut and dry so I was hoping
it wouldn't have to come to this but we
do in fact have more severe methods to
accurately determine if one is in fact
oh god that's horrible
good don't you never talk that way about
there mr. Rathman tell that seventy two
three years in a federal penitentiary
for committing perjury Jared you're free
to go I almost put you away for life no
can't do this judge I'm super gay I'm
trans again I'm crazy crazy yet oh oh
ma'am
I know hey did you like this video it
what you didn't oh you're a cat person
well that makes sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video you know what crazy cat you
can get back you couldn't you can
comment below to as to why you don't
like it